[Music]
your birthday was last week happy
birthday thank you citing I know it was
really fun yeah what did you did you do
anything fun for your birthday I think
it was fun I went to Las Vegas yeah
[Music]
everyone can get behind that idea right
away what did you what kind of adult fun
are you into gambling gambling
you see there's like an anger behind gay
to be defensive I like it a lot
okay yeah like illness stage I mean like
how much do you like gambling I don't I
mean I like it a lot it runs in the
family and actually and you can't stop I
know my mom you know really loved
Kipling a lot my father says like honey
the planes leaving shut up she's the
nicest well I've always really should be
actor like what the craps table or some
blackjack table the budget table on your
doubts that we got to go he's leaving
she's like really angry
so I've controlled myself yes show them
so so what happens like you get there
and when your what's your what's the
game that you like to play blackjack
okay you like to play blackjack and are
you one of those people that I can tell
the people that are really tough is
they'll sit there for hours and hours
and hours is that you yeah really and
and then it's that you just don't want
to go and do you have a way to protect
yourself from losing a lot of money yeah
I don't really personally to you if you
lose you take a person Chi I can't help
it
but I feel like wait I had a 12 and then
I was lucky enough not to break I got a
17 and the dealer gets a 19 what's
happening something's wrong yeah this
dealers not breaking like the fix is in
right I can't they like it when you
accuse them of cheating in fact I think
I'm smart enough to know control those
outbursts that's good that's good so you
control yourself I'm just curious like
do you get your your your there you're
at the table you're there for a couple
of hours the other gamblers must they
recognize you you're very recognizable a
huge celebrity like what happens when
people does that throw you off your game
is it bother you it bothers me because
you can't talk to me while I'm focusing
on what cards coming up next because if
I focus I might know right what it is
right because God will tell you I don't
know how I divine the information but
huh not saying it's God because that
would be crazy right I just know you
just know so so it did they try and talk
to you about like hey you know I want
your autograph or anything like that I
mean what do people say to you when
you're when you're at the table for
hours and hours yeah well the fun thing
was this happens a lot a lot where so
this last time someone came up from I
don't know what country but you know he
came up he had an accent and and he said
you don't photograph well with a big
proud smile
like ready for this you don't photograph
something else is it because you are
better now what and I said okay that's
great because the career I've chosen has
me on camera
you know it's funny men compliment no
you don't think it is a compliment
because I'm telling you people come up
to me all the time and they say oh
you're much better-looking in person and
I'll go Oh cuz on TV and you're like
they do this I don't even know what that
is but the experience of me it's not
good
yeah all right that way but here in the
sandwich shop you know